[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen in Sallys Welt
es wird mal wieder Zeit für einen
nachgemachte Reihe
mein Team hat sich gewünscht aus dem
McCafé den schokoladenmuffin tada
[Musik]
bevor ich euch jetzt Zutaten vorstellen
kann muss ich den natürlich erstmal
probieren also es ist ein xxl-muffin den
backen wir gleich in so einer XXL Form
wir haben jetzt mal anschauen oben drauf
Schokoröllchen
da ist er der
oh mein Gott ich habe gerade meine
Kindheit vor Augen kennt ihr diese
kleinen Kuchen
kennt ihr das wer kennt die kleinen
Kuchen die sind so klein und da ist auch
so Schokolade drin und die sind oh mein
Gott ich muss kleine Kuchen kaufen das
war meine Kindheit wir haben immer
eingefroren und dann war die Schokolade
knackiger und dann gefroren gegessen oh
mein Gott kleine Kuchen und genauso
riecht es
habe eine kleine Kuchen okay also hier
sieht der Schoko kann auf jeden Fall so
aus als wäre er eben Nachhinein
reingespritzt worden mhm schön saftig
und schön schokoladig
und noch oben drauf
schmeckt halt machen wir zugeben ich
finde den Schokomuffin nicht schlecht
schmeckt halt aber industriell
hergestellt das muss man dazu sagen also
der hat halt schon immer so ein
Beigeschmack mal weißes kommt nicht von
zu Hause aber ich finde es nicht
schlecht aber den können wir besser also
machen wir jetzt mal eine Zutaten Fahrt
und dann backen wir diesen leckeren
schokoladenmuffin nach
ich habe jetzt hier die Zutaten für euch
ich verwende vier Eier jeweils 300 g
Buttermilch und Sonnenblumenöl natürlich
Vanilleextrakt 400g backmehl oder
normales Mehl plus Backpulver 300g
Zucker eine Prise Salz ganz wichtig und
60 Gramm Kakao ich habe hier wie gesagt
schon meine XXL Muffinsform die ist
einfach etwas größer als herkömmliche
Muffinformen und habe auch hier diese
tulpenkaps nennt man die weil es einfach
aussieht wie so eine Tulpe so eine
Papier drüber und natürlich könnt ihr
das Rezept auch in einer normalen
Muffinform zubereiten in der normalen
Größe dann einfach halbieren also 12
Muffins werden jetzt hier raus und wenn
ihr diese Menge halbiert habt ihr einen
normales 12 Muffins ähm großes normales
Muffinblech
egal genau das habe ich jetzt schon hier
den Ofen habe ich auch auf 180 Grad
ober-/unterhitze vorgeheizt und
eigentlich sind Muffins immer recht easy
ich nehme jetzt den handrücker Gerät
weil es mehr Zutaten sind ihr gebt die
flüssigen Zutaten hier rein also schon
mal die Eier und ihr könnt jetzt auch
hier mehr überlegen ob ich dann noch
einen anderen Geschmack mit rein nehmen
wollt ich muss die Eierschale immer
gleich entfernen
ihr wisst ein Fakt über mich ich mag
keine Eier
keinen Eier Geruch und keine Eier hier
in der Küche auf der Arbeitsplatte
deswegen muss es immer gleich weg mit
Essig ausgespült werden ja und ihr könnt
hier immer den Geschmack mit reinbringen
das heißt entweder Buttermilch nehmen
oder auch noch Kaffee mit rein ihr könnt
Kakao nehmen also ganz wie ihr möchtet
aber ich halte es neutral denn der
Schoko machen schmeckt nur noch Schoko
das war's schon und jetzt kommen hier
die trockenen Zutaten dazu und alles
wird gut eingerührt und sobald Mehl
irgendwo dabei ist nicht mehr so lange
rühren gerade bei so lockeren Teigen
damit das ganze nicht speckig wird
sondern schön locker dann nehmt ihr euch
jetzt die Backform mit den
Papierförmchen und wenn ihr meine drei
Eisportionierer kennt ich habe die
kleine Größe für die minimuffinform die
mittlere Größe ist er perfekt für so
Frikadellen und alle möglichen die große
Form ist für die normale Muffinsform und
ich habe jetzt hier gerade das ist noch
mein Testmuster denn ich hätte auch gern
für die XXL Form einen großen vor allem
auch für Pancakes und alles davon nehme
ich jetzt eine Portion und wenn ihr den
großen eisportioniere habt dann sind sie
immer zwei Kugeln
ganz einfach
ich hoffe ich habe mich nicht verrechnet
aber ich habe dann das Volumen
ausgerechnet und dann quasi mit den
anderen und dann halt es hochgerechnet
Volumen der Kugel dann halbiert weil
seine Halbkugel ist und dann müsste es
eigentlich reinpassen und dann habe ich
den Durchmesser ausgerechnet und dann
hat er mir das mit dem 3D Drucker
ausgedruckt und jetzt ist er einfach
funktioniert da
und ich werde jetzt checken ob's passt
[Musik]
exakt 12 Stück ich liebe es wenn meine
Berechnungen aufgehen jetzt kommen die
Muffins in den vorgeheizten Backofen bei
180°c
[Musik]
nach dem Backen werde ich erst die
Ganache herstellen denn zum Befüllen
darf die Ganache noch warm werden
zum Fertigstellen der Muffins brauche
ich 100 Gramm Sahne 200 g
Zartbitterschokolade und für die
Dekoration entweder so schokoröhrchen
oder wir machen Sie gleich selbst aus
Zartbitterschokolade und weißer
Schokolade ich will mich ja noch nicht
selber loben aber ich finde die sehen
schon perfekt aus also die hier
sehr schön richtig schön sind die okay
ich kann jetzt hier die Sahne einmal
kurz aufkochen lassen da wird jetzt eine
Ganache gemacht
und zumindest die Ganache wird schon mal
viel viel viel besser schmecken weil ich
gleich eine super leckere Schokolade
dafür nehmen ich habe immer ganz gerne
die Kalle Schokolade und die ist einfach
muss ich sagen geschmacklich ohne
betrefflich deswegen betätigen auch
schon sehr lecker und sehr gut werden
kurz aufkochen lassen und sobald sie
kocht ziehe ich sie vom herunter also
mach den Herd aus und dann kommt die
Schokolade ein rein und wird eingerührt
[Musik]
fact sieht die aus die lasse ich jetzt
hier kurz stehen und nehme jetzt hier
entweder eine Spritztülle oder ihr nehmt
einen Apfelentkerner
also so ein bisschen Eröffnung
reinmachen
und zum leichteren befüllen nehme ich
jetzt in der Dosierflasche und da kommt
die Ganache rein die ist jetzt auch noch
schön warm das ist auch wichtig und dann
könnt ihr damit jetzt die Muffins
befüllen und hier nehme ich einfach nur
den Deckel weg und setz den noch mal
oben drauf und dann noch meine
ordentliche Portion Ganache drauf
[Musik]
gut berechnet
Mathematik okay
jetzt kommt die Dekoration
dann nehme ich mir jetzt einen
Sparschäler und einen Block Schokolade
weiß und dunkle Schokolade und dann
kommen jetzt hier noch so Schoko
Weilchen drauf
[Musik]
fertig und ich würde sagen ich hole mir
jetzt mal eine fachkundige Jury damit
wir die McDonald's Muffins und die Sally
Muffins verkosten können die sehen so
gut aus
[Musik]
Murat du kannst in die Küche kommen
hi hallo
ich habe vom McDonald's
beim McDonald's aussieht aber ich kann
es nicht gegessen aber ich kann es mir
schon denken
weil der dunkel und und dann zeigt immer
das wahrscheinlich voll keine Ahnung
ich wollte es nicht erklären keine
Ahnung aber ich glaube
wir probieren gleich
wem würdest du optisch gesehen den zu
geben was sieht optisch schöner aus die
finde ich den hier eigentlich fast
schöner ohne Witz
aber ich finde den optisch auch
Geschmackssache optisch dem den Punkt
und jetzt gehen wir mal an den Geschmack
aber ich bin voll ehrlich ganz ehrlich
also nicht nachher sauer sein wenn du ja
auch der jurora weil du immer am
ehrlichsten
jeder soll
eine schöne saftige Schokolade gefüllung
ach Samira ist auch da Samira Schatz
[Musik]
dann machen wir gleich mehr Punkte also
ich habe ein McDonald's Muffin gekauft
und einen gebacken also nachgebacken ich
sag euch nicht welcher was ist welchen
findest du optisch schöner hast du schon
mal einen Muffin bei McDonald's
das ist egal ich möchte nur wissen
welcher schöner ist einer ist vom mcCafé
und einen habe ich gebacken welcher
gefällt dir besser
okay dann würde ich sagen den habe ich
ja schon aufgeschnitten
[Musik]
also
ich werde ja was aber ich glaube ihr
habt euch schon entschieden
gebt ihr euren Punkt
aber ich finde auch tatsächlich dass der
geschmacklich dem vollnark kommt und wo
liegt der preislich also preislich mal
hier bei ungefähr 289 pro Stück und hier
bei ungefähr 40 Cent
ist mir ganz wichtig zu sagen bevor
jemand sagt McDonald's gibt hier die
Leute ab das sind Arbeitskosten drin die
mir natürlich nicht rein kalkulieren
können
günstiger aber
ja ich will euch einfach zeigen der
schmeckt gut
und ihr dürft selber entscheiden
[Gelächter]
welches Rezept welches Gebäck oder
welches Gericht ich einfach als nächstes
machen soll macht's gut bis zum nächsten
Mal
[Musik]